what would your answer be to the old
question what is the meaning of life on
our stay here on earth
Oh wonderful question one that we
started with yesterday uh you might ask
it this way what is the greatest
question that humanity could have
answered for itself well you know in
classical philosophy they said here's
what classical philosophy is about who
are we where did we come from where are
we going
these are the three questions everything
arises from this each leads on to the
other
uh I've tried to I've tried to look at
the question where did we come from and
have proposed theories about it
uh I've by looking into my body brain
with drugs and meditation and just
analytical thinking I've tried to look
at who are we and then the great
unanswered question is where are we
going you know what is to be the destiny
of the human race are we an episode in
the biology of this planet or will we
build a meat strung along the Milky Way
and from there to yet grander and
greater things we don't know how much
intelligence there is in the universe
but we certainly know that something has
broken out on this planet in our species
that is like nothing else in the order
of nature what if we are nothing more
than a virtual zip on the face of
reality well if by virtual you mean that
we are inside some kind of artificial
simulacrum region just software being
run yes uh well then the question is by
who and to what end I could get that I
my life is so much like a story that I'm
constantly at
in the question right what sister who
writes this Stephanie who thought me
thought our fella that put us talking
like this in front of 22 million people
that doesn't happen in reality that kind
of things happens in our of the very
finely whole sort and so I want to know
what is the medium and who is the artist
and who's paying for this production
[Music]